wow what's going on there i have a
stomachache
i did a laser today and they gave me a
vicodin
and i think i bent and said i took it on
an empty stomach so
what's that common side effect okay okay
well benton's right what's [ __ ] new
so i just have to lie down so i'm sorry
about my weird background and then i
look like i'm in chemo
two most gorgeous women i've ever seen
and i'm just like hey
hello and welcome to the feels good
podcast i'm amanda cerny
and this is jacqueline fernandez you
guys like pull it together and put some
makeup on and look pretty
oh sorry
our guest for the week is whitney
coming it is here to make fun of us
stand up comedian producer writer
actress
um animal activist uh
you're just everything and anything
you're amazing at so
listen very long professional
like lie downer on podcasts
i've actually never done this before and
i love it it's a testament to our
friendship like this is that i'm
doing this and i feel no shame or
embarrassment i hope people are inspired
yeah exactly and by the way terms when
you can show up the best way you can
i i'm like so many people would have
just canceled
and you did it amanda i
never canceled you know that about me
yeah
that's true another reason why i love
you so
freaking much like i cancelled out
amanda
to make plans for about eight months
she did but i knew we were gonna be
close friends and i was like i don't
have time for this right now
i know we're gonna just like we're gonna
suck up so much of each other's time
let's just do this in a year
but the thing is your her cancellations
jacqueline and they weren't
like um just because she didn't
want to do at least like i think because
she didn't want to do things it was
because she actually had
like real [ __ ] she had to do that like
took priority to it because she's a
businessman
of course there's like so much on your
plate
there's so much is the best thing for
the other person
it's the best thing for you i'm not
gonna show up half-assed
resentful tired like overworked
fitting you in hey okay let's just do
the thing it's like you this is
my thing like why did you i can't stand
it when people show up
to a meeting or an appointment we've had
like and they're like
i'm like you knew i scheduled time i
went i ate
i waited don't sit up don't snap with me
my skin just falls off from my laser
yeah which you're doing
you set the halo laser can you tell us
about it i'm dying to know i'm obsessed
with this stuff i did the halo laser
okay so the first thing i did
uh was there's this machine
you're telling me it's not necessarily
great where they
um put a machine on your app yeah
and it's equivalent supposedly to like
200 sit-ups or something
yeah and i was telling uh whitney
that it's good when you do it with um
movements and like workout movements not
interesting
they do your butt whoa that's cool
and it's hot i'm totally sore the next
day
like my back hurts i'm exhausted look at
the booty
yes the booty shakes yeah how often do
you have to do this i think you have to
do it five times
i mean i haven't you know done the whole
thing at five times
in like three weeks or something and
then
okay you still work out like you know
amanda's saying and you still you're not
you know a total
sack of garbage and then i did
the hail oh you could also do it i did
it on my arms for the first time today
what really yeah you look like
you're just all strapped up yeah i was
like
work out for the day done earned me into
wonder woman i don't give a [ __ ]
are you allowed to show boobs on this or
will we get cancelled uh we might
youtube might not allow it oh yeah
that's a good point okay so this
was the halo laser let me try to get my
boobs out of it um they're kind of
covered just see that
yeah if i just do this hold on okay
can you kind of see oh yeah it's like
it's a little blown out yeah oh nipple
sorry there you go
wait wait where are you doing it on your
neck on my neck and i'm gonna do my face
also uh next week and they basically
just set you on fire
um and it makes more collagen we'll see
and then this is
like after you can kind of but your skin
right now
is glowing like you have such amazing
skin
thank you a lot to it but you can kind
of see
the wrap you see the red outline yeah
such a pretty picture too like i know
you look so hot
i was on viking and that's
apparently but yeah i do i'm not wearing
um foundation right now because i just
couldn't do it
but um i oil my skin
all day i have oil around me at all
times i do it constantly i when i wake
up in the middle of night to pee i have
oil there i put oil on i reapply in the
middle of the night
um i sleep in headphones that look like
amanda's wearing so that my product
doesn't rub off on my pillow
i still back down facing up
um never put my face on a pillow ever
ever ever ever
ever um and obviously upward motions
only i see people putting on makeup and
sunscreen going down with their sponges
and down and pulling
up only so i grew up um with horses
and i had to clean saddles and i had to
um polish saddles and i learned to treat
your skin
like a piece of leather you don't ever
want it wet
i never put water on my face or body
unless there's oil involved before i go
in the pool
before i go the bath has oil you never
let uh your face
be wet for any reason cause it swells
it's just gonna know it's gonna dry it
out and parch it think about a piece of
leather
you wanna keep it oiled up moisturized
out of the sun and never
water damage look what water does think
about a piece of wood or a piece of
leather
and think of your skin like that only
upward motions
when we're putting on anything makeup
anything only up
even the neck people go like this when
they're it drives me even with my legs
and my arms only up
what is this people are pushing their
skin down yeah
no that's exactly but wait a minute when
i was doing these gua sha
um like exercise like know those like
those um
treatment they like they were like oh
you have to keep doing this
wrong direction wrong direction up only
up only
i think i think they were saying that um
for lymphatic drainage because like they
they were saying it's here but it's also
up here too
so all the people are wrong like yeah
i'm not
i'm not clowning from him but i've
gotten so much bad advice like i don't
even get facials anymore
because it's all about digging in it's
all about squeezing zits it's all about
like
like hands-on i'm like no it's i was
just scheduled for a facial today
really you can do it yourself you can't
put oil but i have so
i have i feel like i have so many things
like that i want to like
remove i know we have like blackheads
and stars
okay yeah but that's on you so that's
like on scrubbing
exfoliating use the lotion p90 or the
p70
exfoliate scrub p90 or p70
uh it's a biological i can't believe i'm
giving you guys now it's gonna be sold
out and i'm never gonna be able to buy
it
but you don't need someone else's dirty
ass fingernails to squeeze out your
blackhead and then put a bunch of oil in
it and then you're gonna
go out in the in the pollution people
get facials they open up their pores
they steam their pores they squeeze a
bunch of [ __ ] then they go out in the
miami air and all the pollution and [ __ ]
just get stuck to their face
after facials i break out so much more
yeah
it's just your face is porous and it's
made of tiny little holes so
if they're gonna open up your pores and
steam your pores and then you're gonna
go out and drive in your car and touch
your face and put [ __ ] on it it's just
like
i i quit doing that a long time ago it's
such a racket
but i know what people are thinking
right now is you're saying oil on your
face and
when people think of oil they're like it
clogs your pores yep yep no but uh
actually it took me a long time to learn
this because i was the same way i have
been on accutane twice
full disclosure when i was 16 when i was
21
which shrinks your oil glands is what
it's supposed to do but it didn't really
work for me because i had
cystic zits i was at war with my skin
and i was
squeezing and and um uh what's the stuff
salicylic acid and zip cream and
toothpaste and i was just like
and you're making it worse and when you
squeeze you're actually making a deeper
um uh hole the other way
so you if you're gonna squeeze you go
from under and out we tend to do this
and then it just goes deeper that way
right so i didn't understand anything
but i was
constantly trying to dry my skin out
which exacerbates it makes it worse
and finally a dermatologist explained to
me that when you put
the more oil you put on your skin your
oil glands stop producing as much oil
because they
don't need to so you're actually oil
on your oily skin is good so my skin
finally got good
when i started lubing it up all the time
because my my overactive oil plates were
like we need to produce oil because
they're so dry
and then i get these cystic clog things
you know yeah so there's absolutely no
foundation on your face right now
there's no foundation on my face but i
do have on um eyeliner and um
look at those eyes like how clear is
your skin
like you don't even have any like i have
marks well i have this is happening
i've got i mean that's yeah
but that's still just yeah i mean i mean
it's improved it's so clear
i work so hard at it i'm not one of
those people that's like i
just might like i work so [ __ ] hard
at it
and before i put my makeup on i wash my
hands
like i'm lubing up all day constantly
sunscreen i wear gloves when i drive i
wear hats like
it is a hustle three questions
um what sunscreen do you use
do you use like a mineral one yeah no i
just a lot of it is just like
it's trash like so much stuff is just
trash i use right now the shiseido um
uh oh the how do you pronounce the
benton uh ch
chanca tanel but also ch she's santa k
shanta kay the one that's in the tube a
makeup artist used it on me it's wrong
i really good really gooey
and amazing i like the super goop also i
do too
i like super goop and then i like all my
um
uh foundations uh have sunscreen
you know and it's just yeah then in my
car i've got uh the spray for your hands
the aerosol spray that's got an
owl on it the spray oh
oh wait i know that brian i forgot the
name it hasn't the one with the owl
even i forgot that spawn beach bum oh
yeah
anything kind of natural that's like an
aerosol spray but as soon as i get my
car
spray my hands go to my appointment get
back in my car spray my hands like
spray my neck and this side of your face
is always when you're this is this is
what happens when you're driving
just you're getting pounded by sun on
this side so
get back in the car spray it pat it
i used to do new face i can't believe i
just remembered this the new face
machine
um i used to do the new face machine
always in traffic every day all day
really i see it on airplanes
what is that i love that machine it's a
microcurrent
uh yeah i just you're in the car you're
sitting there you're on the plane
you're like just you know just just
burning my face in public constantly in
ubers
i but okay and then how often do you
clean your brushes
for your makeup mention how often do i
clean my brushes
every two seconds never i don't use a
lot of
brushes i don't have brushes i love
fingers i use my fingers
and then here i just a little bit of
blush i don't put
any i never put blush all over or powder
all over my face that's why i'm so
greasy i don't brushes are abrasive to
the skin
why i mentioned saying no i don't you
were using a brush on me the other day i
felt you were cutting me with a
razor
is the worst when someone uses like a
really bad brush
oh my god benjamin's over there like i
did not
eyeliner and it's like hard and we're
just ripping at our
eyes like here's the thing i also made
so many mistakes for so long
i did tanning beds in high school i did
champion beds a day
like i'm on borrowed time um
i also did ulthera once a year
for like three years and then i just did
again this year
that's supposed to be really good though
thermage and ulthera
are supposed to be like really good for
collagen production
and just like tightening of skin i mean
i've
like i've seen people who've done it who
have amazing results
and it's great you can also do it on
your arms it's for loose skin
uh from what i understand or to it
traumatizes your skin so deeply that it
starts producing collagen but you i also
did it on my thighs
my arm my arms um it hurts like all hell
it is incredibly expensive so
i would just make sure it's like the
right your dermatologist like this is
what you need like a lot of people want
to do the threading stuff but that's
like
it's not time for that yet you know and
if the doctor tries to push something on
you that you're not ready for it yet
they're just
trying to make money so don't let you
know don't let them do that
like so how often are you doing
treatments like how often do you go in
for treatments
not that often really i mean i
once he goes once a week
but like you're all about
like once a year like [ __ ]
um yeah once a week well cause not every
other day
if i've got like a cystic thing i'll get
a cortisone shot i get
filler on this side of my nose um
uh is that even it out or something yeah
because it's
it's really broken and i don't want to
get a nose job and i don't really give a
[ __ ]
so bro did you like were you in an
accident
you know it was just i mean many but it
was not
one thing that i haven't broken but um
no it's just really crooked
and it's like a scoop and when it's lit
at a certain way it just looks
crazy so i was like i don't get a nose
job let's just do the
they just said let's do filler so but
what i like about
how you do things is that you try things
you like
really analyze things and research
things before you even do it
and then you create your own like this
[ __ ] doesn't work list
this [ __ ] is good and you challenge even
the professionals of what they're doing
with
you so it's like you're not advocate for
yourself you got to ask questions
especially women go into doctors and
they
walk on eggshells like as if i'm
bothering you
like i'm paying you you're gonna i'm
you're not gonna rush me
you're you're not gonna rush me out of
here i have a list of questions that are
written on a piece of paper because
you're gonna [ __ ] frazzle me because
you're gonna come in and you seem so
busy and you're like
okay what's going on and like why are
you stressing me out i just sat in your
waiting room for 45 minutes
and you're trying to rush me out of here
and you're probably going to be like oh
it's just your period like i'm not
letting you rush me
you have to claim your space in there
and go what is this what is this i want
to see pictures
i want to see the before and after i
want this i want a blood test i want
proof i want data
why are you why
behaving as if they're they're doing us
a favor work for me
i'm about to pay you 300 for 14 minutes
like i'm not doing this so
right it took me a really long time to
not be scared of and intimidated by
doctors when i went in
especially with women they dismiss us so
quickly and they know they can
[ __ ] sell us anything especially if
they're capitalizing our insecurities
like doesn't make you look younger
so this happens what does that mean when
how much time
like you know and then we're they're not
[ __ ] us
so they don't want to have to listen to
our questions like there's no
so then you gotta have to just be like
look i'm we're not dating you're getting
nothing out of this except
for my business um
and i'm gonna ask any questions i want
but when did you start doing that
was it just a natural instinct or was it
like in business
you started doing it for yourself and
then it kind of related into every
aspect of your life
i am in almost 10 years in a 12-step
program called al-anon which is
when you grow up in any dysfunctional
home uh
and you are essentially a doormat
and you walk on eggshells around
narcissists and
and try to pee everywhere people please
they're in a shape-shifter and you just
want to make everybody else happy
and then this program teaches you how to
you know stand up for yourself and
advocate for yourself and build
self-esteem
and you can't build self-esteem if you
don't do a steamable action so i see a
lot of people on instagram that are like
love yourself and i'm gonna
like when's last time you did something
for someone else like like doing
being of service for f for free with no
strings attached like
so there's a lot of service involved to
build your self-esteem
like i have low self-esteem how are you
gonna get it well it's not gonna be
thinking about how low your self-esteem
is like go do something for someone else
that's do esteemable action so it took
me a long time to sort of get out of my
me me me my selfishness how do i make
myself better go take out your
neighbor's trash because he's old you
know go do something else
um that's what's gonna give you pride
and respect yourself purpose
people are only going to respect you as
much as you respect yourself it took me
so long to realize like
like because i was just wanted
everyone's approval all the time and
it's just
it's needy energy it's unattractive
people don't respect it
um and uh it's it's it's um repellent
when someone comes up to you it's like
hey can i it's been [ __ ] annoying you
know it's just like it's
not it's obnoxious there is that that
that term which is like over
niceness where it's like i i know what
you mean because like i think like we
are really sensitive to stuff like that
just like human beings in general like
when someone's being overly nice
it's like it's just not natural and it
seems like there's a motive
is she it's just like you don't have to
why are you advertising it
just be it you know like you're
advertising it just
like someone's like how are you i'm just
like hi
i i always like would be jealous of the
people that
i don't know if jealous is the right
word but other people that could do that
like just go into groups and just be
like
like and just like because i like
get with me she's like
now i have to participate now
why no it makes me feel so
like it's so hard i can't
no i have to cringe and now i have to
act now
you're making me you're making you're
testing me in your shitty movie
that i was a [ __ ] before and then and
then everyone's seeing me be fake
so everyone's like who's this person
like
but yeah just like when amanda when you
come over i'm like hey what's up and
then i'll come see you
i love it i'll see you when i see you
like i'm not
there's oh yeah it's not the best thing
ever every time like i
am it's taken me so long to be the same
person i am all the time
and no like and it's actually working
with uh
training rescue dogs and working with
horses has really helped me understand
like
when you respect yourself and claim your
space um
the no one's leaving at least the white
people aren't
so i used to associate hey what's up
with like they're gonna leave me they're
gonna reject me they're gonna abandon me
if they do
that's that's on them that's not my
business
and the way that prey animals and dogs
work is they
they have a thing and then they get over
it
they have a thing and they get over it
you know there's no held resentment of
like well she didn't say hi to me first
and i got her a gift that was 30
and then she got me a gift that was ten
dollars like they just don't
think they don't calculate they don't
keep score so
yeah i only [ __ ] with people that don't
keep score
resentments in if you have a resentment
towards me that's your problem to solve
because running around stomping your
feet and being mad and giving the silent
treatment like i'm not going to notice
like you're taking poison and expecting
the other person to die that's
taken me that and i also did emdr just
real quick which is a like a
um eye movement reprogramming and
desensitization if anyone has deep
trauma in their childhood
alcoholic homes abuse abusive
relationships an accident car accident
fire
something like that like it's a great
like check check
um so the way that i'm gonna just
explain in layman's terms because i'm a
layman and i don't um
i'm not a scientist but it uh
essentially the way our brains work is
that
you know a lot of people say like i have
anxiety i'm stressed out i'm anxious and
they're not sure why
we should all be anxious everyone that's
got anxiety you should have anxiety
right now we're in a pandemic
things are uncertain everyone should
everyone's like we gotta cure our
anxiety it's like no this is
your body is is doing the right thing
given this
it would be weird if you weren't anxious
right now so i have a little bit of a
tricky thing with anxiety um but
eye movement reprogramming and
desensitization so when a trauma happens
to us
so say um uh uh
amanda this was what happened to me so
uh ish
uh you're in uh it's christmas morning
nope bad example let's say you're at a
restaurant
uh italian restaurant there's a red
tablecloth and there's booths with
leather
and there's candles and you're having a
pasta
and you're next to your uh your dad and
your sister
and a couple other there's a family next
to you that an asian family
next to you there's a you know black
family next to you whatever
there's a fireplace there's a chandelier
all so someone walks in
who's drunk off the street a homeless
person comes in and [ __ ] just like
smashes something down and hits someone
in the head and runs it's like a freak
freak trauma right a freak accident just
a weird you almost get hit by a car
coming out of the restaurant whatever it
is
and your brain uh freezes
uh and basically our brain freezes and
we stop
because that's our way to say is the uh
stay as still as possible because the
threat might just move past us there's
nothing to do right now right
and then essentially our brain takes in
about three billion pieces of
information
a second feel touch smell hear
everything and when your brain freezes
in trauma
everything that you're taking in files
in the folder of trauma
yeah this is this is dangerous so
you're sitting at you there's a red
tablecloth and you're like anxious and
you're like picking fights with johannes
and you don't know why
and you're just like i don't like being
here i don't like this person
and like you you don't know why but it's
filed in your brain that like red
tablecloth like something bad's gonna
happen
and you need to be honest your body
doing its job to keep you safe you know
the asian family the black family you're
like okay there's
like you don't know why you're freaked
out you're just freaked out you know or
you're racist
um but uh the the boot leather booth
like i just don't like these other
booths like this [ __ ] guy that i'm
gonna date with like i don't like this
guy he's [ __ ] weird
like what's going on with you and your
history and your file folders and so
what eye movement and reprogramming
deceptivation does it eventually take
those things out of the folder my
one of my biggest traumas was on
christmas day in front of a christmas
tree
and i could not i
starting december i would just be
checked out
no christmas tree no christmas no
holidays until like six years ago i did
the emdr
and now it's like i'm christmas all year
round the smell of christmas trees
the candles all at christmas i just like
i don't know presents i don't get
presents we don't have christmas parties
we don't like i was just like my brain
was like
christmas is not safe you know so wow
so what does the therapy do um is it
like meditation
it's not meditation it's um uh so it was
uh discovered in the 70s by a woman
um who uh it was a tree it's treatment
for a lot of like um
soldiers that have ptsd that come back
from wars um
and uh because they associate everything
with charlemagne
you're holding something in both hands
that vibrates
and um uh you have to move your eyes
back and forth as you
describe the trauma of what happened
and they prompt you and ask you
questions of like okay the man came
in and he grabbed you by the throat and
you're like going back i mean it's
it sucks it's hard and then it's like
what was on the walls
what oh [ __ ] there and i remember just
being like and this thing happened
and she's like what color was the carpet
i was like red oriental rug
christmas christmas gift shiny christmas
gift like
i was like oh my god that happened on
[ __ ] christmas you know like i had no
i
i didn't know i forgot like you black it
out you know so
it like walks you through it you're like
there's a dog there was a small dog
there was a
the staircase and my sister was there
and there's two
like you start to
figure it out and and then you take it
out of the trauma folder
and then it's like i'm not you know it's
a miracle
and clearing the cookies you're in
you're clearing your cookies
wait so i mean like then what with the
difference between
like therapy like normal therapy
um and this than me oh normal this is
like
um this is like knocks out years of
therapy
i mean it's like a shortcut normal
therapy whatever that means most people
can't afford it
most therapists stay sick i'm sorry drag
it on
but yeah i would say free therapy or 12
step programs
everyone qualifies for either al anon
aca overeaters
codependents you can get free medicine
and 12 step programs
i think talk therapy in my experience
often re-embeds your trauma
and it it fortifies the stories that
you've told about yourself
i was abused as a kid and my mom was a
bad mom you just
keep re-embedding [ __ ] that might not
even be true
just yeah true you know so my but the
reason my therapist is
you know such a genius is that she goes
you need to stop talking about that
that's not what happened
like you're not a victim that you're not
a victim anymore so she would say i'd be
like i just feel abandoned by my
boyfriend she's like adults can't be
abandoned
you have a car you have a house what are
you doing so it's like she's just like
cut it out you know and a lot of
therapists will just sit there and let
you
just talk your drivel and you know
charge you a bomb yeah i'm not i like i
remember going to this guy
when i was trying to get out of a
relationship and he was always like i
was like should i leave should i say
he's like it's premature we just don't
know we're just gonna have to
and it was just like i want someone to
say no
you're not doing this like i just want
to be like bossed around by someone i
respect
and then i want to be given homework so
it's like people are like i go to
therapy once a month that's like going
to your personal
like get the gym once a month you're
what it what you're gonna do
you know so it's 12-step programs
reading
aca big book codependence no more like i
got to do that every day i got to do my
outreach i got to do my sponsorship it's
like extra it's a muscle in your brain
to stay happy you know um so regular
therapy like
i'm i know there's good therapists
everywhere but if your brain's not
changing if you're not making new neural
pathways like i was like i want to stop
apologizing so much i'm so apologetic
like all i do is
and she's like you don't get to
apologize for 30 days unless you've done
something wrong it takes that's how long
it takes to make a new neural pathway i
don't want to complain anymore
you can't complain for 30 days and when
you do you have to start over
so that's how you build neural pathways
and break old habits
it's she's very neuroscience based she's
very attachment strategy based
um and uh you know she doesn't let
anything slide you know she's 30 years
sober and
in codependence and she's just like
that's not true
that's not right and i'm like well this
person was rude to me and she's like
it sounds like that person just kind of
wanted to ask you a question and you
were busy
and you hadn't eaten lunch that day yeah
she gets you out of your
like twisted thoughts yeah sort of like
we got them honestly like we have these
stories about ourselves all that stuff
happened but we amplified it or
minimized it
based on what we needed our psyche
needed to
we can't blame our parents as kids
because
it's too traumatizing on the psyche to
think that we're in the
um uh protection of people that are
incompetent so we have to blame
ourselves i'm not good enough i'm not
funny enough i'm not smart enough i'm
not pretty enough because that's the
only
way we don't go insane and then you get
older and then you blame your parents
for everything when they
did not in my opinion i don't think any
parent wakes up and is like i want to be
a shitty parent today like
they all did the best they could and and
this program
uh you know has taught me like radical
forgiveness like we forgive others not
because they deserve forgiveness because
we deserve peace
and we've been trained to be resentful
we've been trained to hold grudges we've
been trained to be
appropriate people and it just it holds
us back
yeah this the crazy thing is whitney
like me and amanda were just discussing
this the other day and we were talking
about like
like the secrets to happiness
because both me and her have a really
bad memory
okay like we just can't remember i'm
gonna stop you that's a story that
you're telling
yourself that's a narrative that i don't
don't talk about my friend like that
it's like
i have a bad memory like okay says who
says you yeah i just i do remember stuff
maybe it wasn't important yeah or maybe
you're not you're not
like amanda i can't remember the first
kiss
first time we had sex i don't remember
you were [ __ ] wasted who cares like
this is true for
years so it's like but do you remember
to [ __ ] put out a video every week do
you remember to [ __ ]
do 18 hours a day do you who who decided
that remembering your first kiss
is your hippocampus doesn't give you oh
my
you didn't get a check at the end that's
why you don't remember it
okay so our brain remembers things where
they get a dopamine reward or some kind
of adrenaline involved
our brain has no vested interest
you're gonna [ __ ] minimize yourself
and be like i have a bad memory
and i'm about like get the [ __ ] out of
here dude yeah
you're right you're right you're right
because like why are you why are you
why are you like clowning yeah like that
it's like yeah that's true
i've ever met you remember
to write edit and shoot 24 hours a day
and i can't remember to turn off my do
not disturb her
and you're like leaning on this
self-deprecating thing of like i have a
bad memory it's like no you just
remember the shit's as important you
showed up today you remember this you're
here
you're right no i like it i don't even
remember
my childhood first kiss my first kiss
ever in my life i don't remember
so maybe you're right it's just like not
a thing for me i'm like
or when you stop crying it'll come to
you or like who what do you need with
that information just make it up i don't
know
yeah well it's not really a tool i could
utilize later
i guess we gotta check survival remember
that you know
okay no gives us [ __ ]
i do remember my invisible wedding
though
so that's my the only wedding i'm gonna
have but
you had a wedding what invisible oh
an invisible light it's like you guys
didn't have one
yo whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
i'm gonna say something else in a second
about memory and music but
i used to take curtains and put them and
stand behind them and then walk through
them and pretend i was a bride and that
would
go over my head
right now kiss the bride that's actually
so cute but that's this is a new tool
that i just kind of really
discovered um listening to old music i
have this playlist of just
songs from when i was like 14 15
16 that i listened to on a loop and
benton's gonna like blow his brains out
if he hears it again
um the atlanta sports set and tori amos
in
your memory you'll start remembering
things like i started remembering
stories and
[ __ ] that happened and things that were
like
that my parents did that were awesome
that i just was like oh yeah oh my god
we this is when i went to the cd store
and he bought me an elena s'mores set
we waited in line for holy [ __ ] like my
dad
nailed it like it helped me old music
or music that you listen to in your team
make a playlist of just that music for
you guys it's like ariana grande or
something
on instagram it happens watch watch my
so-called life for me watch the shows
that you watch when you're 15 and start
seeing what comes back to you
yeah the cosby show cosby show
i was trying to do sudoku i used to
watch that all the time
that's off the air i know i so what do i
do
no it's a [ __ ] great show martin was
my favorite sitcom
uh oh yeah i used to watch that or full
house i'll watch a full house
on the same full house
yeah i mean i think there's an opening
with laurie lovely gone
i feel like you could slide right in
there whitney do you have any upcoming
projects
anything that we can like talk about oh
she has her podcast
the good who are you podcast which is
actually amazing like imagine all the
anne benton
as well who's off camera right now yes
but uh staring at me menacingly
he's like let's play um but
the feel uh feels good that's ours good
for you podcast
is you learn i mean i just learned so
much from you
even alone in this episode and like yeah
just now
though she's like wait a minute i have a
good value we're working on this i talk
too much i just
no you don't talk enough i'm like i
literally have a notepad next to me
back to it yeah yeah that's true but
then i have to go through the whole
episode again i'm doing bullet points
here
taking notes time management take my
[ __ ]
amanda i just love that you just like
take my [ __ ]
i ain't never have to worry about your
feelings you're not like i just that's
like that's the kind of [ __ ] i live for
it's like
showing that women can [ __ ] go
like be silly with each other yeah
there's this this stereotype that we're
all catty and we can't get along and we
can't
make fun of each other it's just not
there's just this narrative that women
are
made of glass and we're so fragile and
we can't [ __ ]
function and so it's it's just so cool
that you
let me be a bully oh my i love it it's
my favorite thing
i think a lot of a lot of my humor is in
teasing others too so that's why
well because you give it right back to
me
that's family you know yeah i love it
and i
like i'm always i always communicate or
at least i try to
communicate how i know you do this too
and
i know we all do this but communicate
how i feel
when i feel it and you did it with me
once we shot a video
and you texted me and you're like i
don't think we should post this here's
why
and it was just like so direct so all
business like
you're exactly right and i would say
just the flip side of that
jackie's already heard me say this today
to gabby which is like
um feelings are facts also
so if you're in your emotions and you
like want to confront somebody about
something like
if you're coming from a place of
emotionality like
give it a couple days and then if you
still feel the same way so it's like if
you're coming
from a visceral place that's like i feel
uh neglected or
of left out or angry or triggered or
whatever it is that's not the time to go
confront somebody
you know because you're gonna you're
gonna the problem for the solution
come to the problem with a solution
which is here's what i need
here's what i want and here's why don't
come like i just feel like you're doing
things like no one's listening
yeah yeah it's where you're calm you're
able to talk about something
um concise say what you mean mean when
you say don't say it mean
clear um because you've got about in my
opinion
if you need to confront someone about
something you have about 30 seconds
to make your point yeah that's that's
about the amount of time you have before
you're going to lose them
no email should be more than two
sentences like
you ha like you the more you talk the
less people listen which i need to learn
i need to work on that say what just say
it
in one sentence what's that oh i
i think my mindset is when i when i see
i want to explain my thought process so
if i'm like
yeah i know it we're not dating people
yeah
i'm like this is this because this and
this and then this and then this is
as a creator and as a boss you do need
to explain to people the target
so when someone says why don't you do
this joke and you go no
that's not helpful because then they
don't know what you want no because it's
just too dirty and this is gonna be on
youtube and here's
why so then they're gonna go oh god i
know they need to know how you think
they don't
know how you feel right yeah
no that makes complete sense no that's
yeah
i i feel like i i was actually in one of
like the best
therapy sessions right now i know this
this was better than therapy this is
what like everybody needs right now
like yeah i can't tell you like i had a
friend over the
the other day and she was talking to me
about her
ex and she just found out that he just
like committed suicide you know and i
know it just got really dark but
it's just like people and
where they're at mentally right now it's
such a struggle for so many different
people so you providing that information
freely
for people to go ahead and work on
themselves and know that there is
like a way out and by the way you have
like
i'm gonna get in trouble for this but um
the
worst thing for us is isolation like
it's our brain thinks we've been
castigated from the pack and don't have
protection of the tribe
um there's an app called clubhouse it's
not public yet
where uh people can connect to each
other would talk about anything they
want and start rooms like
people need to connect to each other and
right now we're being told we have to
isolate
and i'm so sick of looking at screens
and looking at my own face and like
you know that um i'm finding myself
isolating a lot
uh the cornerstone of the 12-step
programs is outreach and getting on the
phone with someone and listening to
their
problems not just stewing in your own
there's always someone that has it worse
than you
and as long as you're focused on how bad
you have it you're never gonna have
perspective and you're never gonna be
happy
people like i need to be happy i need to
be happy it's like well you have all
these things like
the the most successful people i know
are miserable
it's like because you have nothing to
compare it to because you don't
expose yourself to any other walks of
life you're just in your own little
bubble and you're like
miserable and it's like cute and gets
you attention or something like it's not
cool to be unhappy like it's like
wanting to change something about your
i'm gonna move my couch and then move it
and i'm like my couch won't move like
you have to do it and it took me a long
time that nobody owes you anything
and you have to do it yourself and you
can't sit around and wait for someone to
make you happy and fix your problems
it's just
they won't they can't even fix their own
it's not actually when you can do it
yourself yeah more power than you think
there's
yeah you have more power than you think
stop waiting around for other people to
solve your problems and
and make you happy and stop thinking
that a meme on instagram or like an
inspirational quote is going to change
your childhood it's just not
yeah like you have what's your favorite
platform to post from like what platform
do you enjoy being on the most
i'm so bad at this [ __ ] i mean i
like you think you're bad but you're
actually
amazing like yeah you have so many
followers as well like
okay all right now you're just no but
you do
you know
[Applause]
no no your content is raw
it is because you what you do is you're
professional you're a writer you're in
traditional hollywood you're putting
together like cute massive
productions and then for social media
you show a side of your life that they
don't get on in film and tv that they
don't see
and that's what people really and that's
what makes them feel connected on social
media it's like
the more raw the more people are
interested because it's real it's
authentic and they can really like
connect
through it and i think that's why you're
so great a million plus
anywhere like it's just it is a lot of
people it's like
also real i didn't realize people
they're also
real people so that yeah i looked at a
bunch of people i'm like damn they have
so many followers and then they've got
like
5 million followers but they get like
200 comments and i'm like oh
wait wait a minute it's fishy
quantity stop trying to get the people
that don't [ __ ] with you just just
like you don't need that many people to
be successful you just need hardcore
fans and you made a promise to them
and you have to deliver every time and
you have to be consistent and you have
to become their addiction
and uh you cannot spend all your time
being like well i want more followers
just [ __ ] satisfy the ones that
already [ __ ] with you
which is why it drives me nuts when
people post benton's gonna pout at this
but
when they post their tweets on instagram
i'm like
i just saw it i follow you
why am i getting punished because i
follow you on all these platforms
i will say like a video that says follow
me on twitter make a funny video that
says follow me on instagram
don't don't sloppy
some people use other platforms in
different countries
that's true why are you like whitney
by the way i also you're instagramming
and i see that you tweeted it i'm like
so now why am i going to go to your
twitter you put all here i have no
incentive to follow you on twitter now
because you put all your [ __ ] here
that's true you cannot
you cannot post the same clips on every
[ __ ] channel
i stopped you lost my trust i just said
that today
i posted a tick tock to instagram
well and i don't even know what you just
said so i don't know what that
means but uh you're on tick tock
but by the way tick tock benton pointed
this out how are people have five
million
followers on tick tock and the same
person as 20
200 000 on instagram there's some
sketchy about this
is something the numbers on tick tock
because you're not off
like at the end of the day when this is
all over and you get tickets for a live
tour
are tick-tockers showing up like are we
selling out tickets like how does this
translate
to real it all just feels a little shady
to me
i i thought the same thing but then
i started seeing like whenever i would
shout out my instagram on
um tick tock
the kids weren't allowed to have
instagram oh so it's really yeah it's
really really young
yeah because they were like my mom
doesn't let me there and it's like oh
wow
children yeah i don't [ __ ] with children
and they'll find you on there though say
to them anyway but
yeah and you also have to like for me
i'm like i'm gonna stay in my lane i
can't try to keep up with stuff that
you know i'm not relevant in like i
don't like i'm glad i'm older
i'm wiser i know what i have to offer
like i can't keep chasing
like now i'm a youtube star and now i'm
a makeup tutorial person like i just
said like that's not my skill set and
there are people that are better
qualified
than me let them have the spotlight like
them get the money
very few people can do stand-up comedy
in a special for an hour i'm just gonna
do that that's what i train for
that's my sport like i don't you know
people that
you know go to the olympics for
basketball are just like i want to be a
swimmer it's like
why not why not do the thing that you
you made a promise to yourself and you
got good at something
and you owe it to these people to keep
giving them the thing that they kept
paying for they said
that's so true though you guys supported
me
now i'm gonna give up you know so you
guys came to my shows do you bought my
tickets
you helped me get better i'm not all of
a sudden you're like yeah i don't do
standup anymore i want to be a tv
i want to be a movie star now it's like
yeah that's not what we wanted you to do
i think like all of these opportunities
are there all of a sudden like on social
i think like for so many different
there's there is like
okay you can now do makeup and you can
do your tutorials and you can do your
master classes and you can do your
styling and like
i think all of a sudden everything's
like opened up so i feel like everyone
feels
that like i mean i guess
at some point everyone does feel like
they have a like a skill set they just
they just want to put out there that's
apart from what they do by the way this
is coming from someone who's 38 years
old
who doesn't is it if i was 22 25
28 i'd be like i'm on [ __ ] everything
and i'm but i just i'm
i was like on myspace so it was like i
you know
i kind of miss my window to sort of
jump on every stage you know and i'm a
little bit like
i'm gonna do what i'm good at i'm in my
groove i
can't chase things that other people
deserve
i think you do what you i think you
still do what you're interested in
like what you'll put the time in for
like even with your skincare like
all that stuff you're you're not the
time i'm done with my skincare routine
it's it's 4 30 so i can't be on all
these
plastic but you're more educated than a
lot of people that are doing skincare
on your podcast and share my wisdom and
then you get the money
and spread it to your fans okay thank
you but i also want to get your oils
like i want you to make your own job and
then i could just buy from you because
i have confidence but actually what oils
do you use
i'm curious now grapeseed oil tomato
seed oil
nothing needs to be more than 40 50 um
grape seed tomato seed do you like use
coconut oil
coconut oil is is is good but i just i i
usually um
it's usually like creamy kind of and
it's just sort of
globby so i just do seed tomato seed
that sounds great you said you're making
your own line
yes and i are working on our own line of
oil
you know this more than me it takes 10
years to get one label made i don't
understand
but you're also a perfectionist like no
i'm really not in this i'm just like get
get me something and it's like
an excuse it made more than fifty
dollars you said
that's our packaging made of gold um
but uh because benton is is my
sort of guru and understanding people
want something special they want
something oh excuse me okay
hello so cute how's it going
he's my little ow oh i got a tail in my
eye
those are weapons oh my god oh and it's
like all bone
yeah legit legit weapons
whip i miss that i miss my dogs doing
that to me for some reason
i'm like oh like that in my life the
trauma being
fighted by a tail so like like watch
where you spend your money you know
like spend money and women own black
owned brands like
you know be conscious in the way that
you consume because it's going to change
like the way you feel about yourself you
know it's like
the way you spend your money is how
you're building your self-esteem
you know if you go and spend eighty
dollars on a eye cream that
lasts for three days you just feel like
[ __ ] you feel like you've been played
because you have
and you feel bad so to me like i
when i'm like oh i got the grape seed
oil or like i'll go onto an expensive
uh website like neiman marcus or another
porter or something they'll be like
there's a gorgeous like rainbow cardigan
sweater that's five hundred dollars and
i'll go i want a rainbow cardigan
sweater
then let's go to etsy and google vintage
rainbow cardigan sweater
and the [ __ ] it'll i'm you we're
gonna wear it a couple times a year
you know like and then you get it for 35
bucks and then you get to give money
to a vintage store an independent owned
thing and then you feel good about
yourself and then i'm not like i just
spent 500
out of cardigan i'm going to spill
coffee on and then my dogs are going to
piss on so satisfaction lasts a lot
longer than
yeah like you've got to get ahead of the
shame
you got to beat the shame before it gets
you you know
well there's so much to learn from
whitney
make sure you guys check out her good
for you podcast
listen to her instagram she is on tick
tock whether she knows it or not she's
there too
yeah put posting for me well good job
ben
so she's killing it and then twitter as
well she's everywhere
you can just follow whitney winning
companies guys
and thank you so much whitney for doing
this like i mean
again like showing up even in
when just after treatments and like not
feeling so well and you're still here
delivering i mean everybody reads some
life into me so thank you
well this is fun i want it i want it to
go on forever
we'll have to while everyone's watching
this going can amanda
and jacqueline talk about their skincare
secrets because you guys are [ __ ]
glowing angels i have makeup on
your face is [ __ ] no honestly like
i'm like obsessed with your skin it
looks so
good i can't believe you have no
foundation wait i'm 38
and have did tanning beds for five years
wow huh wait do you drink or smoke then
just went say thank you
thank you no
i don't really drink amanda you i drink
um six to six wine
um every day all day
um
but i don't drink a ton uh
i'm i'm a little too like control
obsessed
um i i drink hard kombucha sometimes
then i'll have some wine
i don't i don't drink a ton but that's
what i come from but that's not my
go-to thing yeah i think that really i
can't help so i
love smoking i [ __ ] love it and when
i'm
on the last stretch of a script or when
i'm like it's the best thing in the
world to just chain smoke like
i'll chain smoke like a pack of
cigarettes in two days and then i won't
smoke for a year
wow like it's your vice it's moderation
is not my thing but
when i do it i'll go hard but i i can't
it's it's i can't
it's another i can't even find my cell
phone i can't keep track of a lighter
and
it's sugar for me mine are like out like
cookies chocolate so yeah that's a drug
fine that's good it's the stress that
you um
emit worrying about what you're gonna
eat is actually more aging and worse for
you than just eating the bad thing
yeah oh that's a good one that's really
good because they always say how like
sugar is so aging but then
it's so true actually like the more i
think like you like stress stress is the
biggest ager right
the base asia but also you have to
surprise your body
so if you're eating sugar every single
day not great but it's like
that's why the cheat days work and and
stuff like that which i also think is a
kind of disordered eating in my opinion
uh if somebody's had a lot of it but
yeah you just have to be um
surprising with your body have three
meals a day no snacking
uh this is just from dr david agus who
just
anything smart i've said medically just
plagiarizing him
but you can't do it all the time that's
all you know it's just like
sugar's bad for you it's like okay well
everything has sugar in it what are we
talking about like there's
these gross generalizations that just
make people shut down and be scared and
confused
don't eat any salt don't ever eat soy
it's like we'll have it once a week have
it once a month
like it's you know and they change it so
much too that's just
like everything i've been eating for two
years
like it's not it's just like out
it's moderation stop the stress of it
is so much worse the cortisol
deteriorates collagen so if you're in
the airport like i don't know to eat
there's nothing vegan there's nothing
that's you
know what i'm saying just eat the banana
eat the whatever it is
so that you're not i just i can't waste
any more in my life thinking about food
i just i have too many things i want to
do there's too many things i want to
accomplish like i was not
on earth to obsess about food and
calories i did it for 15 years i did my
time
but i looked at uh food as fuel
i ran benton today i don't save food
anymore i say fuel
you know food
is like fat and bad and
and fuel is i'm like what am i going to
have for fuel today
we always produce i love it that is such
a good one
that works for my brain it's i have a
combative relationship with it i'm
scared of it i have shame around it
amanda are you writing this down
your food is fuel fuel yeah i can see
that i can see that's what should we
have for fuel tonight what should we
have for school
this afternoon i love that that's
something that
was being really sneaky about it as well
she was like let's go
let's call it fuel cause then i go oh
[ __ ]
i'm gonna eat way different if i think
about it as fuel
food because food is like sloppy and
indulging and
gluttonous and like ways you makes you
feel bad about yourself like okay now
i'm gonna have that
you know i'm gonna have that i don't
have vegetables i'm gonna have some
juice i'm gonna have
you know i'm not just gonna eat the
[ __ ] you know so yeah
it changes and then i think about myself
as how am i gonna feed a kid
how would i why do we feed ourselves
trash but if we had a five-year-old we'd
be like you have to have this and you
have to have
this and vegetable and the thing and
then we're adults and we're just like
eating [ __ ] bars in the car
like just trash yeah yeah
oh it's true it's a good one you guys
have been trying to get off for a while
let's do it
no bye whitney
[Laughter]
yeah she's amazing thank you guys so
much
we'll pull it whitney and make it
straight straightforward and
sign off thank you guys love you
that was crazy oh my god bye everyone
thanks for
seeing us on the feels good podcast i
love her so much
you